je m'appelle miles morales j'habite à
Brooklyn ici je suis le seul et unique
Spider-Man et franchement ça se passe
super bien ok
ça va
pas du tout du coup tu es plutôt une
vache ou un dalmatien je suis la tâche
c'est pas drôle non en fait pas ça
de très bonne note 18 en sciences
physiques ça c'est mon fils et 12 en
espagnol
faut que j'y aille au revoir ce garçon
vous ment et je pense que vous le savez
[Musique]
tu veux faire un tour ouais
non tu es sérieuse il y a une équipe
d'élite avec tous les meilleurs speeder
héros c'est qui le nouveau c'est
incroyable et c'est que le hall d'entrée
Miguel hoara il est à l'origine de tout
ça comment on fait pour rejoindre la
Spider team tu ne pourras jamais en
faire partie et surtout qu'on ne parle
pas de Docteur Strange ni du petit
intello de terre un œuf neuf neuf de
bœuf
s'il te plaît vas-y molo avec le gamin
il a eu un mentor et potable
je reprends la main
être Spider-Man c'est faire des
sacrifices
tu dois choisir entre sauver une
personne
et sauver tous les univers
renvoie moi non je suis désolé mais je
peux faire les deux Spider-Man réussit
toujours à toujours et au club ben ils
sont enclub ben la plupart d'entre nous
ne seraient pas d'ici
[Musique]
tu ne pourras pas fuir éternellement
j'ai refuse de perdre un autre ami c'est
parce qu'elle était au courant tu ne te
rends pas compte des conséquences
tout le monde n'arrête pas de me dire ce
que je devrais faire
moi je vais écrire ma propre histoire
[Musique]
normal
toi
[Musique]
laisse-moi deviner il était mort